one of the game's most tenured lefties
jon lester 37 years old in his 16th big
league season his first with the
nationals just his sixth start because
of a delayed beginning to this year he's
off to a 0-2 start he's really struggled
his last two outings here is colton wong
to begin things chops one past the mound
first base side fueled by zimmerman a
quick underhand toss to leicester
covering in time for the out and willia
damas will be the batter swinging a miss
struck him out with a cutter two up and
two down for john lester here in the top
of the first inning and here is garcia
swinging a ball hitting the air to right
center playable for soto coming in
and coming in further with the wind
holding that one up makes the catch and
it's a one two three inning for john
lester another veteran lefty it's 33
year old brett anderson his 13th big
league season when he has been healthy
he has been one of the game's best
ground ball pitchers and this year is no
exception trey turner scheduled against
veteran left-hander brett anderson
adamus
on the first base
and era on the receiving end turner
despite that great speed is that number
one one away for juan soto hiro who is
not a first baseman by trade but playing
there ever since colton wong arrived in
milwaukee plays that nicely soto retired
two out as ryan zimmerman comes up lines
this into the corner and a fair ball
zimmerman a two out stand up double
with two outs put schwarber aboard two
wrong with two out four castrols strike
three called right at the knees inning
over
nationals had a hit strand two john
lester's ready to go in the first pitch
to lorenzo kane is grounded towards the
right side and through a base hit lead
off single for the brewers center
fielder sets the stage for manny pina
pina
lifts this
channel left schwarber want to win
here's urias
there goes kane
the throw the tag and they got kane at
second base john gomes does it again but
a quick release he had to throw it
sidearm
and threw a bullet to jordy mercer 3-2
what a partner drops in for a base hit
as zaria's it's a two-out single how big
is that throw by yong gomes it'd be one
nothing right now casta climbs in with
two ounces in a manna board swing and a
miss struck him out with a cutter
second strikeout for lester no runs two
hits in the inning josh harrison stands
in
into right field past colton wong not an
easy thing to do harrison is a born
lead off single so now it's jan gomes
charges this to center field
not deep enough though kane is there to
make the players go and smoked it but
right to lorenzo cain what one away
there's jordy mercer mercer breaks his
bat what a leaping catch willie adamus
at short fine play there's out number
two brings up john lester in play colton
wong takes his time
to retire the side harrison's lead off
single goes no further on with two outs
for one of the hottest brewers avisaio
garcia swinging he's jammed in a pop-up
shallow right mercer going out soto
doesn't see it a late break coming in
and mercer has to make the
over-the-shoulder catch bailed him out
there soto did not see the ball at all
and that almost turned into a disaster
and so turner steals his 11th base one
away now for zimmerman swinging a rocket
to right field this is going to be in
there it's going to be down and by the
right fielder garcia to the wall
turner will score zim on his way to
second he's in there standing with
another double puts the nationals in
front one to nothing so the brewers
trying to come back after falling behind
one nothing see if they can put an
inning together against john lester here
in the fourth louisiana is now the
batter
rips this into left field that's gonna
drop in front of schwarber out there
kane around third he's headed for home
and he's gonna score brewers have tied
it at one brad boxberger the marlin last
year he's going to face trey turner
where the base is loaded in a 1-1 game
swinging a ground ball up the middle
it's off the glove of the shortstop
adamus into the center field gombe
scores now there's a traffic jam bell
goes to third and mercer standing there
kane comes in he's chasing bell toward
third and will tag him out actually he
missed the tag but bell's out of the
baseline
and so the nationals run into it out
there on a play in which they take the
lead so now the brewers will just
intentionally walk soda the bases are
loaded for zimmerman who is two for two
with two doubles in an rbi today
and he lines it into center coming on
his cane he's there to make the catch
and the inning is over brewer is able to
limit the damage oh man josh harrison
goes over toward right center playing
only his second major league game in
center field and commits an error and
yelich will get the extra base the tying
run is in scoring position for the crew
and it turns over to the top of the
order in colton long drive out to right
going back on it is soto at the track
it's over his head in right field yelich
is around third he's headed for home
colton wong has tied this game with a
fifth here's willy adams first pitch a
soft chopper trey turner bare hand a
little option pass over to third and
they got him at third what a play
by trey turner
incredible
what just happened we got a high school
quarterback out there in shortstop
that was unbelievable daniel hudson
now pitching for the nationals facing
garcia comebacker
mercer has it turner a pirouette and
another dazzling play strap some gold on
that glove trey turner what a defensive
inning for turner first the brilliant
play to get the outed third and then the
amazing double play it's a lead-off walk
to kane go ahead and run with speed put
on base matter now is porius
off into the corner it's a fair ball
kane is steaming around and he scores
standing what a night luisa
and he puts the crew in front in the
sixth inning it's a sacrifice fly for
jackie bradley jr now the brewers now
lead it four to two now colton wong will
be
a little flare dumps in for a base hit
travis shaw thunders around and he
scores the runs keep on coming in for
the brew crew in the sixth inning
they're in front five to two
thomas a fair ball yelich is in to score
now the brewers are just now piling it
on in the sixth inning 6-2 milwaukee
it's up to ryan zimmerman change-up
struck him out swinging
devin williams after giving up back to
back base hits to open the frame comes
back and retires the top three in the
nationals order
yardley is on to
get the final three outs
final hope tonight for the nationals is
jan gomes ground ball hit towards short
adonis has it he's gonna flip to colton
wong
that ends the ball game and the brewers
have swept this double header a 6-2
final here in game number two in
washington d.c